Speaker 1: Former Trump adviser Stephen Bannon
recently sentenced to jail for four months. But
free pending an appeal, is now openly threatening
Dr. Fauci and his family with being, quote, hunted
if indeed Republicans take control of at least the
House in November in the 2022 midterms. Bannon at
this point, is an overtly dangerous and disgusting
figure in American politics. Truly sick. Here
is Steve Bannon. FAUCI What is wrong with our
country that they want to go after? FAUCI They
are obsessed. And here is what Bannon had to say.
Speaker 2: On the 8th of November. And when
we destroy the Democratic Party as a national
political institution and really end the regime.
Speaker 1: By the way, the use of the word regime
here is totally propagandistic and inaccurate.
Speaker 2: The hunted become the hunters. The
hunted become the hunters. So and you heard
Natalie at the top, the whole Fauci family
is going to be welcome to the investigation.
Speaker 1: Why Fauci's kids? Why are you going
to investigate Fauci's kit? I mean, putting
Fauci aside for a second, his whole family.
Speaker 2: The entire fam family. Remember,
Warren was taken off Twitter because of comments
I made about wait for it, Christopher Wray
and Anthony Fauci that their day was coming.
Speaker 1: But that has nothing to do with.
Speaker 2: Fauci took us down. They took
the boardroom account. I've never been on
tour. They took the worm account on Twitter,
paybacks across the board and all that big move.
Speaker 1: Wow. Retribution. They're going to hunt
people as retribution. This guy is truly
disgusting. I mean, think about it being
mad at Dr. Fauci because threatening him got
you banned from Twitter for first of all,
what does that even have to do with
Dr. Fauci as question number one?
But it's like a blame the messenger sort of thing.
It's the most base and disgusting thing. And
understand that, you know what? Why is everybody
why are they on the right so mad at Dr. Fauci?
It starts with something that is typical of cults.
Foushee committed the mortal sin to the MAGA right
wing cult. He did not kiss the behind of the
Orange Emperor. He said, Hey, you know what?
We shouldn't inject bleach. That's not a good
idea. Hey, you know what? We don't have evidence
that hydroxychloroquine works to treat COVID.
It's anti-science. It's overtly pro ignorance,
pro hate. And it's also contrarian for the sake
of being contrarian. And there's you know, we've
talked a lot on the program about conspiratorial
thinking. We've talked a lot on the program about
cults and cult members. Oftentimes, the cults
promulgate conspiracy theories, and sometimes in
addition to the brainwashing and all the different
stuff, there is a desire to be contrarian simply
for the sake of being contrarian. Conservatives
and Trump supporters should be mad at Steve
Bannon. Bannon fleeced MAGA people way more than
Fauci did. Remember that Bannon? Fleeced Trump's
supporters out of millions of dollars and is in
the middle of criminal prosecution. For remember,
the whole build the wall thing, give us the money
and then will build the wall, which of course,
they weren't doing and they didn't. And now
there's there's a prosecution happening.
The MAGA people should be angry with Ben and not
with Fauci, who gave the best medical advice based
on what we knew at the time at all points in
time during the pandemic. But now they want to
hunt Anthony Fauci. And this is absolutely a
form of stochastic terrorism, meaning with a
large enough audience. If Bannon continues shining
a spotlight on Fauci and his family hunted, Fauci
and his family hunted, people in the audience can
get the idea. Maybe I should be the one doing the
hunting. And sadly, Dr. Fauci needs full time
security because that is indeed a real threat.